even on abortion the Democrats have gone
completely insane and it's now the
Republicans who are moderate more
moderate on abortion so there was the
Republican uh no sorry there was the
Ohio Senatorial debate a day or two ago
this is JD Vance the Republican versus
Tim Ryan the Democrat and they went in
uh to discuss abortion as an exception
look I've always believed in reasonable
exceptions this is a misrepresentation
of my view but let's hear it from me
it's not from Congressman Ryan uh I I
absolutely think the 10 year old girl
the case that we've of course heard a
lot about an incredibly tragic situation
I mean look I've got a nine-year-old
baby girl at home I cannot imagine
what's that what that's like for the
girl for her family God forbid something
that like that would happen I have said
repeatedly on the record that I think
that that girl should be able to get an
abortion if she and her family so choose
to do so but let's talk about that case
because why was a 10 year old girl raped
in our community raped in our state in
the first place the thing the media and
Congress and Ryan they talk about this
all the time the thing they never
mentioned is that poor girl was raped by
an illegal alien somebody that should
have never been in this state in the
first place you voted so many times
against border wall funding so many
times for amnesty Tim if you had done
your job she would have never been raped
in the first place do your job on border
security Don't lecture me about opinions
I don't actually have okay so there's
two things happening there and I want to
show you what the moderate position is
and then we'll get to Tim Ryan's
position in a minute first on the
abortion part now he JD Vance who is
pro-life it is his personal and
religious belief uh in life okay so he
does not want abortion but he does
believe in some exceptions now me
personally you know this and I know this
is against actually what most of my
audience believes but you still tune in
because you're decent people my position
would be that we find a CO we find just
some common ground thing and it's hard
to do and we can talk about whether
that's 12 weeks I think 15 weeks which
is you know now you're into the third
month whatever it might be and then you
know you could maybe go a few weeks past
that that's for every state to figure
out that's what the the beauty of this
experiment is each state can figure out
what it wants to do and then you're
allowed to move according to that so
JD's position is that he he allows for
exceptions okay in the case of rape and
health to the mother Etc so that's
somewhat of a moderate uh position okay
by the way Florida I've often mentioned
this Florida here which is thought of as
this very red state with a very mean guy
named Rhonda santis in charge has a
15-week ban on abortion which again is
is basically three and a half months
into a pregnancy and nobody's arguing
about abortion here in Florida like 15
weeks it's like the pro-life people are
like you know what we sort of wish it
was less or didn't exist but
it is what it is we live in America we
we understand there's people different
than us and even the I can't say all of
the the Democrats but even a decent
amount of Democrats here in Florida
acknowledge like the moderate Democrats
because we do have actually some
moderate Democrats here in Florida but
they even acknowledge that that's a
compromise so first off so JD he's doing
some level of moderation right on
abortion and then he's also taking the
moderate position when it comes to
immigration which is we have to have a
border that's the moderate position
actually we can figure out all the other
stuff after but a border is a moderate
position countries have borders that's
what makes them countries anyway let's
compare and contrast that with Tim
Ryan's position on abortion my question
was about any limits to abortion at any
point
you know late term anything
look you got to leave it up to the to
the woman because you and I always here
are a bunch of well you and I sitting
here can't account for all of the
different scenarios that a a woman
dealing with the complexities of a
pregnancy are going through how can you
and I figure that out okay so you tell
me guys which is the moderate position
that there should be some exceptions and
maybe a couple weeks or whatever it
might be and we can again hash that out
and that could be decided state by state
or that women should just be able to
decide at eight months or as the baby's
head is coming out uh that you should
abort that baby